[Applause]
um I like your style competition they
don't know they're competing with us
that's going to give us all the
advantage here so I love that
um before we begin it's like to
introduce our great kids our health
benefits we have Alan
uh
[Applause]
it happened
[Music]
they're going to be extremely important
for this session because one of the
first things we're going to do is build
a Docker environment to do some uh demos
on so if you have any trouble with
soccer you just leave us down that will
assist you if you don't have Docker on
your laptops we have a couple fallbacks
you could install the vacancies in like
a home environment although the dock
environment is highly suggestion
and we also have a favorite singing
Edition
will fall back
foreign
garments run demos uh and then we'll go
over a history of the theater
architectures that came before the lake
house architecture and to motivate the
Delta lake at technology
I find that that's extremely helpful to
take into historical context for this
because otherwise it seems very similar
to like why is this a database but
without the people then why do we need
this
will help uh kind of give a distinction
for how this is different than previous
architectures like playlists and their
warehouses and what improvements you can
see and if you adopt this approach
and then we'll move to some demos using
uh Delphox apis
um we'll cover that there's several apis
available to pipeline users
to our reliant on the jbm and one is
reliant on Rust the Delta RS python
vitamins uh they both have advantages in
different situations
um I spark
is apis are set up better for scaling
the rest apks don't require jvm which is
great uh so that's almost enough of an
advantage there although they have a
very active developer community and
they've been adding new features in the
accounts that don't exist anywhere else
within the ecosystem so it's very
exciting
then we'll take a little break uh
personal questions and then we'll move
on to some pandas and Delta RS recipes
and then we'll finish up with a shorter
fabulary question and then you know
we'll be available after the session of
course
okay so this is the powerful we start
building our Docker environment
um so uh this doctor setup was
contributed by one of our open source
contributors
it's really great it kind of has all the
cases you need to start playing with
billfully
the first step is to bonus Rito I'm just
going to let people
Google wallpaper
and then there's just three additional
easy steps and it will start up your two
for lab I have no video game
just a quick show of canvas does anyone
not have Docker installed on the laptop
okay awesome thank you for being
pregnant
um
uh as a backup uh if you don't want to
figure out how to like install instead
of darker or write your sentences
um you can use the databricks Community
Edition if you Google that it should be
the first thing that pops up you should
be able to sign in all right sign up and
sign in pretty quickly for free
and the alternative to that is using a
common environment
um and uh once everyone has a chance to
kind of grab these instructions I'm
going to switch to the next slide which
will show you how to do this
um
yeah
so this Docker environment is great
because it doesn't just have the bearing
in them to run Delta Lake on your laptop
it also has additional great tools for
the open source community
that has tools like our Ro API which is
a rust project which
exposes Delta like tables as respect
guys
and it is great for building web
applications that has a whole bunch of
other goodies so after the talk I highly
suggest you check out the other
tools and utilities that are SolidWorks
okay because everyone have at least the
the docker environment started the build
does anyone need more time on the slide
okay
oh yeah does anyone have questions while
we're filming talker requirements
[Music]
yes if you don't have Docker I'd say the
David's Community Edition is probably
the best fallback
Community Edition should be the person
that pops up
that's pretty quick to sign up
definitely accept card
really easy
it's a little bit slower outside
um so if you end up docker
and also if you need help from a PA
oh we have something we need some
thank you
okay quick show of hands does anyone
else need this slide
I mean
that's
okay so if you're in condolence
um this would be a
way to set up the con environment
slightly more steps
um but
also currently being
a quick show of hands is anyone using
this slide to build a common environment
one okay cool
do you think this side of your mother
a little bit okay
and also if you have any questions not
related to building
oh yeah can you go back to the doctor
just so I can take a picture of them oh
sure you know actually that's a great
idea
um if people want to take uh pictures of
their phone uh
progress and uh just slide me down in
Vermont
assistant
oh
thank you
um if you guys navigate to uh
[Music]
go dot go to that sorry go.delta.io
these instructions are also there
oh slash Docker I apologize
okay so the whale has done its photo up
does anyone need to take a picture of
the conda instruction
s awesome
it'll it'll take a while so don't worry
if it's still building
um that's why we just wanted to start it
is
that's okay we have plenty of time
before we get to a park where you need
it um
that you know you want to rip the
Band-Aid off give the will and the crowd
the reviews and their love adoration
we won't see them again for a little
while so you know
a historical perspective
starts back in the 80s and it goes into
the future
which is very exciting
uh but first uh back in the past
yeah he's calling out the protecting we
have the bunch of cards
keeping me honest
yeah so like in the in the 1980s
there are many things but there's also
data warehouses they're extremely useful
they covered all these cases that we
wanted there's no problem with the
screen
um you know because uh Dr ukl pipelines
and go directly from our operational
databases right into our data warehouses
we have any hiding tables
and we could do our business
intelligence and Report generation
office
I mean you had a few Village today since
it was great uh they were purpose-built
personal analytics uh they had an
indexing capacity and all these tricks
to be really efficient and the powerful
management features and had provided
great things like asset transactions and
time travel can be able to say
uh so life was good
we've gone to 2018 uh there's this
Tangled bisect survey and I think it
starts to reveal some cracks but you
know honestly for ladies that's a pretty
good running
this was a survey of data scientists you
know select any of these activities that
you know prominently feature is part of
your job
and you can select more than one that's
why you know it sums over 100
and the responses were you know analyze
uh data we built chemical services and
you know we run data infrastructure and
so we start to see that you know these
common things that a lot of people are
doing start to fall outside of uh the
model that we had
so there's time to be cracks we need to
start finding Solutions we had
more different types of data
as you go past a certain points those
show their faces
more harder to scale
and so people started to feel the pain
you know we could support this draft of
the group unstructured and
semi-structured data sources
with time servings laws images documents
audio video
and then it just became very
complicitive even if you can spell your
database a relational database system
it's expensive
so we wanted something that was cheaper
that could still build the same role and
hopefully support data science and ml
workloads
one big problem with these workout
systems was that you couldn't really do
data science or ml inside of those you
had to take your data you had to pull it
out and that added an overhead and costs
everything you wanted to do some support
and also now you have a copy of your
data outside of your Warehouse system
that now can become out of sync
so then we had data Lakes to the rescue
2010.
um this addressed a lot of the problems
we had
it was cheap that's why it's most
important that's why it's at the top
uh don't worry about using these it's
inexpensive we love this
um it could be it's a model that could
be run on uh you know the common Cloud
providers
it's allowed us to you know load
specific data into our warehouses that
sensitive processor that still have the
flexibility of storing in our videos our
audio
our unstructured data or text and have
it available for ML workflows
um it was directly readable by those in
the libraries because it was just files
sitting in optics North
super simple
but it wasn't perfect there were some
problems
um
it was cheap to set up that it
very quickly led to complexities of how
you would administer this and you had
still this arm of your analysis that was
still uh the traditional like data
warehouse approach
and you had this sort of messy kind of
uh less uh regulated less supportive
product management operations you know
daily plot of data and so you can start
to get uh pieces of information out of
sync with each other it was difficult to
um
actually have a system sync this in an
efficient way so all that sinking
overhead that it's a slower operations
represent
all those little inefficiencies
and so do each of these multiple storage
systems having known semantics all these
handoffs and specialized
ETL processes it just allowed for more
room from sex to crop up
so that's not great
instead of the daily it became the Davis
one the chip tree Inferno
and then over time that's swamp on fire
it's a complete disaster
didn't even know a swamp people catch on
fire
and so uh as the data set screws daily
persisted
um we've had to turn into another
solution
it's just a quick
recap and I don't look at the bottom
right because that's the spoiler and
that's the solution otherwise you won't
have to stop
um we had data warehouses
it's a great relational database
approach worked great for anything that
was like unstructured or semi-structured
you have any data Lakes uh it was
flexible enough and you're cheap but it
was very complex
and so we needed something about women's
cheap able to scale her arguments with
semi-structured unstructured data and
still gave all the benefits of the data
warehouse or at least you know as
opposed to get to something
oh yeah and we also don't want to have
distinction across all these systems
because that's sort of the sourceless
complexity and added and a difficult
thing but then they were like
architectural
technology
so the idea was we'd still have all of
our data in Object Store and that cheap
storage that we wanted to retain
um
some features of the traditional like
data warehouse institutions so we went
better management
metadata for tracking files things which
cases the data were still which were
like the current versions do you want to
do things like time travel and to also
eliminate the need for things like
messaging cues for syncing between
different systems
we also wanted to build this on open
file formats in the case of Delta Lake
Apache
this is really important because this uh
side steps to issue you have but a
traditional relational database where
you want to do a ml or some more
involved analysis you'd have to pull
that
data out of that proprietary data format
into something like Json or safety or is
something that you can actually work on
and then that would you know perpetuate
that safety problem
so lake house vision is we're going to
have everything based off of this cheap
storage cheap Dependable Storage units
three uh
thank you
okay
[Music]
thank you
and uh so we want everything to be able
to work off this cheap storage and then
we also want to have this like metadata
layer that tells us which versions are
uh still most up to date and we once had
uh you know acid transactions we have
all these goodies of the warehouse to be
able to apply those to things like
videos audio documents
and that will lead us to a better
architecture that you know pulls us out
of this one because if we know it's in
our uh like in our data store and we can
track it we can maintain that high data
quality uh and you can do it without
having to manually create detail systems
and messaging cues and processes to
stick with us
that's sort of the end goal
so
usually where daily is just a collection
of files a lake house is adding that
metadata layer and that's exactly what
data lake is providing it's parquet that
open battle format
on uh Object Store but with additional
metadata to tell you you know what are
the X-Files uh what is currently
partling what is the correct version
and that allows us to have better
tracking and enables us to have a mature
set of management features for our data
and because we know what the active
files are or maybe if it's Etc you can
actually skip everything else and that
improves access for clients that's also
a performance boost to do this tracking
that helps us also have mobile line of
data so we get a trooper
so here's an example of how a basic data
link would work
with
um
a rewrite operation so we have some
events table
and it started Arcade files
and we want to rewrite one to b1p and
we'll delete the previous versions
that way if the client comes along it
won't accidentally access the wrong
version
but the problems of daylight encountered
was what the query means the table while
the delay was running or what the great
Bells uh or or what is the Prairie View
of the Bell is probably you know that
could lead to data consistencies
so we need that metadata tracking to
avoid these issues
so we add additional metadata tracking
that Delta Lake provides we can avoid
this problem
when we rewrite the files
um we also update
a Delta log that's keeping track of all
these transactions and telling us what
is the correct version of the table
so in this case we have multiple
versions of the table version one two
and we're making three
and we'll track which of these parquet
files is associated with each of those
versions
So when you say version two is one two
three and when we do this we write in
delete operation we're basically just
going to instead of actually physically
deleting the files we're just going to
make a new metadata tree that says we
now have a version three
that uses 1B
2 because those records weren't changed
and 3B
so now our
Delta table
um has uh five files
and two versions
but the client will always really
consist of cable version
so before if
um
something fail part way through it could
be consistent data here the client will
actually go to the transaction log and
see what versions are available
and that log won't be updated until all
those prepay files being successfully
price
and because we weren't deleting the
previous files as we were writing the
new files okay they're both there we can
roll back to the previous version
indication
um in addition to having that like
safety uh to parent within the
operations
that you're performing on your display
there's other great management features
that are reporting to us when we add
this metadata
to our our normal data Lake if you have
that time travel versions but we can
also do zero copy exponent of our people
because of the tables the parquet models
actual data itself
plus the metadata that's pointing to
some collection for each version we can
just clone that
transaction log and have a separate you
know set of pointers to the parquet
files and then we can operate off of
those
we can describe the history of the table
because it's just leaving that
transaction one so the same version
files and version two has these etc etc
it's very easy to read through how the
data has changed over time
and then we also have all the normal
operations that you expect in the data
warehouse like the sort of delete merge
which are possible because we have that
access guarantees and you know that we
are not changing anything
without it being completely succeeding
okay so short pans
who's a Docker file is still uh building
cool
it's a little over after oh fantastic
um
I think that's a great time to talk
about this very colorful slide and then
open up for questions
so uh I mentioned in fact way way way
back even before you started building
that Docker file that for the python
Community there's three great big cats
for the Floyd two of those are sort of
Pi spark based apis
um and I was just piping
and the other one is uh this Delta spark
package and I kind of hopefully call it
like the pet spark declarative API
um it has a it doesn't have all the
operations that you can perform a past
part but it has a very clean viewer face
for working with Delta tables and so in
the interoperate so I think it's worth
you know learning both
um and then there's also this newest
client the Delta RX package which is
fantastic I know jvm required
super easy to install and use
um it's a python by nameplus
and kind of just very easily melts with
the rest of the ecosystem because it
passes information between the rest of
the Python and
Arrow which
pandas our favorite Dan Ryan Library
also uses on the back end so it's a very
easy to very efficiently pass
information between the wall
okay so while we're waiting for things
to catch up on the building does anyone
have any questions
or anything that need a life preserver
threat to them
in my life because there are any one of
our kind etas
and we won't throw them so don't worry
how do you deal uh I see that you're
creating new versions of records that
you
need but how do you deal with situations
like where you have regulatory
requirements to delete user data or
whatever that's identifiable yeah no
that's a great question
um so if you have
so there's a I guess there's characters
um you can perform an operation to clean
up and delete uh the actual parquet
files that you no longer want them there
anymore uh
the vacuum operation I would be used for
this
um there's also a set of
patterns for
uh anonymizing or deleting records
um
some other signal so I'd say vacuuming
is the
the concrete answer and then there's a
host of like common patterns to make it
easy
one thing you could do is let's say
uh you have a lot of information by like
company or clients
you could partition your data by that uh
you know object that you need to
potentially drop data form
and then all those uh basically data for
each of those entities went back to you
know you know it's a search arcade file
so basically we would have more than one
user more than one company in a
particular Market file
so that would be cleaning up those
specific files very easy
otherwise if you had multiple days
within the perfect file you'd have to
rewrite the parquet file without those
numbers we need to delete and then
delete the old one
oh
um
so this could be
let's say these are patient records and
you have a hospital and the record says
that the patient is currently
um
in the ICU
and they make a great recovery and so
they are discharged so to make that
change in the patient's record you would
have to rewrite the market file with
that value changed
so you'll be rewriting the whole file
and then you would update the
transaction of one the point of that new
file as the current like version of the
table so like if the initial version was
version zero of the table
um you would rewrite that parquet file
and then you create a version one of the
table that thing that says that file
instead of the previous one
yeah I know great question so uh the
question was uh does the new files just
contained the rewrited records or does
it have everything that was in the
previous per K file and the answer is it
has everything else in the previous
parquet file plus updated records you
know parquet files are immutable which
is fantastic because we know that they
haven't changed
but as a trade-off with that you can't
change them so you have to write a new
one it's not a problem though because
you can perform a vacuum operation not
just say remove an infecting density
vehicles to do it to remove older
versions of the table that you know
offer
I guess you probably don't have strong
feelings about the version of the table
you probably like it just fine
um
and so usually you'll set a retention
policy based upon how much safety you
want around being able to roll back to
previous versions and then uh you know
automatically those older versions and
that potential policy said this will be
cool
uh
oh as you're saying you're saying uh
we're uh we have a bypass a problem with
like data getting that same query and
being partially read or written because
we go to the transaction one first and
then we go to the data itself
and so you're going to say hi you just
push the uh or pass the buck yeah you
just pass the luck what if that happens
with the transaction log
um so we uh atomically right a new
entries to the transaction law and so
when a client goes to read the
transaction log
um it will only see what's considered
written there and this isn't a problem
whereas it is sort of like very very
large data files because these are very
very small files so actually blocking
uh for a moment it's not expensive
um
and so what will happen is let's say
you're you know updating the transaction
log different kind of goes to read it
will be let's say version zero as
version one is being written and it will
continue to read version zero until it's
done with its query and then version one
of the transaction log will be created
and then the next client that comes to
read the table will get version one
let's say specifically ask for our early
version
you know that's a good it's a good
question
oh yeah how do schema changes impact the
log like if I add a new column two data
set it's going to go rewrite old
versions of that transaction marker
sorry for that one more time if I go and
add like a new column to the schema uh
and someone's reading an older version
of the table the transaction block
really see that new column where's the
new column effectively like another
there
foreign
[Music]
and that's actually really nice because
you're skipping all those other birthday
files you're skipping even reading the
whole transaction pond whereas if you
were just to do a file list uh I guess
like S3 or something that would be a
really slow operation
um
so this is like a really nice
performance
oh yeah
the danger of
uh it seems like the transaction pump is
kind of a critical piece of this so is
there a danger of like a race condition
if
different users are making different you
know modifications importantly and the
transaction mode has to get access by
both by different users
it does
um so I
it's not a concern if you're using Azure
or Google Cloud compute because there
are good stories have a method called
uh
but if not happen
um so basically it won't actually
overwrite each other
basically the second writer that goes to
make the update we'll see that it's
already there and we'll throw in there
right and then we'll have to read them
slightly more complicated story
um but not that much it's a
configuration we can figure a lot of
stuff uh basically you set up a dynamodb
instance
um to act as your locking mechanism
because it lacks that API
um if you're concerned about costs do
not worry
um it is not doing a lot of work here I
think someone recently in the community
slack which you should definitely join
if you're using don't play
um says do you like pennies for some
very large number of checks so it's sort
of a grounding error
[Music]
this is like the old uh
we shouldn't say open does uh living
things go sort of Microsoft campus but
it's like
99.9 you're just like
I really want to play Pinball or
whatever right now actually can I
provide some context absolutely okay so
um sorry um there's a question about S3
and all that stuff so just to reiterate
what Jim talked about
um when you talk about asset complex
basically Jim called out the lack of
code of absence now hdfs adlco2 and GCS
do not have that problem now specific
for S3 uh there is a problem because it
lacks put up apps now to give you some
context of the how often this occurs we
founded the what happens is a
um would the transaction law happens
that you've got two systems or more
systems trying to write at the exact
same time what happens is the Json files
create and that's our transaction log so
it's possible in a very small case where
two drivers or two writers are going to
write just the transaction law so not
the data files okay just the transaction
log at the exact same time now what's
the likelihood of this happening because
of this lack of supportive absent is
four times out of 10 million okay so
it's not a common occurrence but we did
catch it and we caught and these are
numbers I'm giving you from 2017. so in
other words uh we haven't touched any
since because we found that
um and so we've been working with the S3
team to actually get that fixed they
promised to fix that
four years ago so yeah so we're still
going on that one so in order to work
around that there's a system called The
dynamodb Log store and so long story
short if you initiate that then that
basically ensures that four chances out
of 10 million that they could possibly
could occur will never happen at all so
that's the longest version It's a
relatively simplistic configuration when
you configure your um you typically will
configure a log store within Delta
um underneath the covers it's actually
automatic for almost all of these
systems you have I believe three
different lines in order to initiate
design when they belongs for those with
their cases okay just wanted to give you
that context
no that's great context so you're
completely covering
how's that looking for a gun
oh speed okay
I don't want that
any other questions because we're
mentioned that one of the benefits of
the data warehouse is supposed to be
fixing how's that handled
amplifier
yes so there's a few
there's a few different mechanisms you
can use to
speed up queries it kind of depends on
the nature of your data
I first saw you might ask this question
I have a bonus life you would want to
so there's a bunch of different
optimizations one is partitioning so
basically sequester all
um
uh rows that have a sort of like
categorical value limit columns in the
zip file and then that would become
crazy
basically what that looks like when you
laid out is there's a folder at our
directory for each of those partitions
and so it's very quick to just go there
you know the balances within that
partition so that's sort of
indexing uh equivalent and then if you
have your hair current value columns so
continuous values and some bad dates to
the ends you can use deodoring which I
won't dive into the leaves
um but uh it's
multi-dimensional clustering for your
data
so basically you can say I have two or
more columns that have continuous values
so maybe you want to Cluster records in
time to also Buffet
um age time and age so like times when
they come to the hospital and the HDR uh
because that's a common query pattern or
access pattern this would basically
locate those records as best you can
because it'll be trade-offs between all
those columns
is partitioning in Z ordering mutually
exclusive can you use both of these
um you can use both
I'm not sure
if there is
[Music]
okay so um
sorry can you hear me yes okay cool um
okay no you can definitely use both
um so the context if you remember like
partitioning basically is setting up the
file system itself to basically indicate
clearly that like using date partitions
right and so Z order basically is an
attempt to say okay can I go ahead and
Skip I.E reduce the amount of files I
have to scan so by already let's just
for the sake of discussion you're
partitioning by year okay and so you
specifically say I want to look at only
data from 2012 right so then by the very
definition you already reduce the number
of files I have to scan or look for
because I know that I'm supposed to look
at the 2012 instead of files Z order on
top of that we'll then go ahead and
reduce I'm saying okay well I don't look
2012 but I also have some predicates
that say like okay where
I don't know
um
product is bikes okay so um so then the
idea is that the Z order helps you being
actually identify within the 2012 set of
files
which ones that are most likely
containing bikes in them so that way I
can reduce the number of files that I
have to look at
right so pretend you're uh a
Sports retailer you sell a lot of
different items right by using Z order
instead of going through a thousand
files for 2012 uh
2022. uh uh for last year um the uh the
idea that you could go ahead and
basically say instead of actually
looking through all the files for 2022
right I can say okay I only need to look
at these 15 files that may contain bike
information in it
so you can absolutely use both now the
only reason I'm saying you can is
because theoretically
you can also go ahead and forego
partitioning all together and just use
the order for the whole thing okay you
can actually do that and zero actually
can handle it
um Z over by itself can handle Spark by
itself can handle most other
infrastructure is not well designed for
that though so that's why I will not
advise you to do it or at least not yet
okay because
um even Sparks primer default of
structure is still to follow Hive style
partition okay but Z order you can
theoretically go do that so in other
words you could just say I've got a
single table I do Z order I'm done
so but again best practice I would
definitely start off with optional
participation
thank you
okay
yes in fact um
that's usually how people uh
the ordering
um
because it's a multi-dimensional like
clustering if you just did it online
column you'd be just ordering the values
and then chucking them which
you know in some cases is helpful but
usually like the place where you
actually see the benefits uh for you the
noble the access update really patterned
it more than one column absolutely name
that's the best case
yeah that's a great question so the
question was
you know if it's best to use the
ordering when you have more than one
column to search across efficiently uh
is there something that is in return
that you know in the extreme it's easy
ordered by all the column until it
happened
uh and yeah they're definitely is so the
more
um calls that you do order by eventually
you get to a point where uh the
constraints you're putting it on like
laying the data out uh kind of the
clustering
um you can kind of think of it as like a
cursive High definitionality almost
but if you're usually won't have you
know it's a factor of your columns
support the cholesterol so
you're almost certainly going to be good
okay any uh lingering Docker file bones
okay
I got a fist bump that's great I like
that interview that's what's going to
make us be the winner is a clacking at
the end of this really show those people
they're replaced in the conference
yeah
there you go
oh actually I shouldn't
go back to this uh
decided effect
um so we have your Docker
um
image builds uh then you should try and
run it
at the pop-up Department if you're not
familiar with Docker what we're doing
here is we're creating interact with the
image of the cold metal or software and
we're not mounting it to our actual like
uh
Black Ops file system so anything you do
in here will be erased so it's a
criminal if you want to think whatever
you typically persistent you can add a
dash B for bonding notes but you also
don't have to worry because we'll upload
these notebooks uh somewhere from one
afterwards as well
so don't worry too much and then the
dash p is defined the reports of the
container to your laptop so you can see
the
um
super laptop
control
I'll just give her a second
and
raise your hands if you have any trouble
starting your container
that would be able
we're going to dive into you know
trading a Delta table and the inspecting
that transaction log so you guys have
some great questions which are great
because it's like I planted too
code in pictures
I know you're not supposed to uh you can
create a blank one and then we'll be
packing along with this
um I just didn't trust myself to live
type as I talked
it's easier to
see and breathe
oh yeah are these networks also
available somewhere
um
they all will run to prepare these
specific notebooks uh I'll post
something after talk so
um
things are all going on YouTube so it
will add it to the descriptions
yeah so this is our kind of model for a
Delta table a transaction block
and each of these uh version marks are a
different version of our Delta table
and we have different
data sets here because the table is
changing over time
so we're going to replicate this
with our uh High support API
foreign
[Music]
and then we'll repartition it to one to
V1 partition everybody this isn't a
Delta flight practitioner this is a
spark partition
and this is just so that when we write
out our data frame it's all in one per K
file
so normally you you wouldn't add this
this is just that we have it all
isolated
so the way that you write as an adult is
you would
right
format and then add Delta and then save
so it's very simple if you've been using
per K in the past you know it's a very
easy drop-in replacement
and then if we would
there we go reflector file here we see
that under 10
got some notes
we have our Delta table
which is
uppercase files that open storage format
that um we can read directly for ML
applications or some other application
without having to actually you know uh
do some detailed process to extract some
characterity or extractive proprietary
data programs and then we also have this
Delta log for the transaction log
so if you click in here you see
that Json so this is the first version
or version zero per table and this is
the first log so if we open it up with
the Json editor it will error
um should be angry
because it has an unexpected correct I
think it's just a new line
so we'll open up the editor which is
just like text editor
and we get to see what the Delta
transaction log actually looks like
uh so at the top we see this protocol
entry
and this is basically telling us what a
version of the vegan writer you can use
on our table as compatible so the Delta
the classification is updating all the
time as the features are added in your
applications
and so a reader would I need to know you
know what features are available and
compatible so there's some information
around that
the mail said some configuration
information
so like right now all the flag tables
have 4K and sort of data format that
related to the specification is the
opportunity to in the future use
something other than perfect
Sunrise came up
and then we have this first record which
is actually adding and making that
initial
so it's adding our parquet file
and then it gives us information on the
sides of the data and occupation time
number of rows
and then inversion number
there he comes
so switching back to the notebook again
I'm going to make a second data
parameter
and we're going to attend this to our
installment table
so here instead of
here we'll actually add our bank mode
for a pen you can also have an override
in which case it was replace the table
with this new data frame but we're just
going to add these records
and then we're going to look back at the
Double log and see what's changed
so before we go to the Delta log we've
seen a second perfect
and that will contain those added
records that would be attendance
and then we see that there's a second
entry
in our Delta transaction log which is
this Json number one
so it has an add action and it's adding
that other file that has a new records
it also gives us the size and
application time
it says data change that's great
and it also gives us
some operation metrics which are helpful
it gives us the number of files that
were added uh the number of output roads
so we added three rows instead of
records that we've added three rows here
and the number of heights so this is
nice if you want to go through and see a
record of like how the data is added
velocity
um
very easily
in this nice structured Baseline which
is also be carriers with the double
indicars
oh sorry I can't quite hear you
oh yes absolutely
here it is so the difference between the
first Freight command and the second one
is we've changed it to low depends first
before we did we discuss it by a mode
because it was the initial writing
oh yeah
um so you'll so there's different
actions of a transaction line
records
and the way the transaction log will
kind of evolve as you interactively
don't say it one more is it will
add additional Json records up until
it's 10 and then it will compact them
into a parquet file which kind of
describes the history of the table
that's that's a lot faster to read
otherwise the reader will let's say if
you haven't hit that check
uh actually checkpoints are really over
and it is a checkbook but
then sorry words uh so you haven't hit
that point yet it will read all the Json
records maybe after that or let's say
you hit one at a checkpoint and you've
done two or three or more uh Json
records it will be the most recent
parque that has the full history and
that will move the additional Json to
get the most recent changes
um so that's a really nice optimization
because RK is very quickly to purse
um the reason we don't write out parquet
for everything and we use Json is it's
faster for you know just a few records
so just yeah it's a Json
um you evade that uh
passion
decompression overhead of the parquet
which
you know for large amounts of data is
worth it
then we'll create another data print
this time we both will bring it
foreign
so here we've overwritten our Delta
table so if we need it we'll just have
those new records and know the old ones
but we still have all three of the
parquets that we've known so far and
that's because uh we have that what
we're right operation we're not actually
physically removed those data files
right we're updating uh what's
considered an active record part of the
filter table in the transaction log and
then that transaction was pointing to
some collection of parfa files that's
associated with this version
whoops
oh sorry
that's a very good point I will wait
just a little bit longer
um
and if people don't just like kind of
look up and give me improving books when
they're done typing
a computer field
and again the big difference here is
that we set mode to open right instead
of a pen like before
and then they go to the Vlog
and here we have an add action
for the new data that we're overriding
with
and then we have two removed actions
removing those previous two parquet that
we had initially written independent
from the Google list of act different k
files in our Delta table
so if a client goes to read the table
now it will
be through and say oh okay so we have
this arcade this parquet oh this part K
is added to those two are removed that's
a set of protease I should actually
review
so that's how it determines the active
records to return for a query
so if you're a
client I was reading you would just
think back to
the Json zero one
and then you wouldn't be able to
reconstruct the state
in history which is next
foreign
[Music]
well don't worry we can restore
and go back and complete different
versions of the data I think
correct our errors
so if we're just going to read uh that's
the table without specifying anything
special and we can just use product we
need to perform at Delta and then we can
load the location of our table
and a reader will know that this
directory is development table because
it will see the double log
and then we'll know to enter the
directory and start leaving Json
reconstruct the history
so when we do that we get the values
that we Overlook until one
exactly what we expected
that if we were to read other versions
then we could pass an option when we're
reloading our health table
they pass it a version as of or later
you had it provided like a date time
so if you do version as of zero we get
the initials from one two
two and the version one
we get diamonds off the table after we
did the initial 10.
and then finally if we do two which is
the most recent version then the
overwritten values
and this is possible because we didn't
actually physically like delete remove
those per k files they're also there
including operations every operation up
until something like a vacuum is just
adding more of the data and like context
which is fantastic all alone keeping is
Speedy the query because you're doing
all this file skipping again
does not matter how it was sorted yeah
there's no uh like inherent order
that's a good question though yeah as
far as that Spark's not about that life
it doesn't
play by those rules
because
absolutely
um
yeah
yeah just be super white yes
if it's angry with me because
the time stamp I provided is before the
earliest version available
that I'd have to take out this whole
thing like if I could have accepts
past measures here which you know I
respect
just like you guys will not accept half
the measures with your clap at the end
like and they're just trying to give it
a year okay or something it's still very
unhappy with me which
sounds pretty
and you know we should have bolt it it
just has high standards but because of
that I usually do the version as of API
it's more accepting
of where I am
and even if I put this time for the most
recent versions that still doesn't work
because I think oh it's still like you
know spray on top of it I actually need
so I actually have to like add a second
until the second or whatever and then it
will return by one
it is nice if you have like a very long
live distributor cable and you know that
you're trying to like grab something uh
a quarter to some event then it's super
handy so it's for like day-to-day
analysis
um probably a version
yeah if you vacuum the table just the
version as I've changed like referencing
version two and I go into delete
versions
yeah so uh that's a great question so
the question was uh I've heard of this
vacuum operation
I vacuum up the files uh does the
version as of the table can like go back
so like because my version 10 says
there's only you have three versions of
the table now is that version 10 now
version three uh no it keeps its version
as of uh so that's like you can put a
table it'll just keep implementing it's
just that there won't be a version zero
through
you know nine or whatever you uh back
with us if you attempt to time travel
uh or read that version it will of
course fail because you've destroyed
that under the parquet but you'll still
you know maintain the record that it
existed it will always exist in their
heart
like
somewhere we don't have time to find
them
okay so uh rolling back up to the
version as of course
um if we try to query a version that it
doesn't exist you know we get
kind of what we expect a nice little
helpful error that will say Hey you
haven't done that yet come back to me
when you have a version before
um but as long as you your career your
version that exists
and you haven't deleted the parquet
files for it will very happily
and then if you want to look at a
summary of sort of the table history
there's this very handy
um
history
uh called if you have under Delta table
this is actually using that declarative
API that I refer to before
um so this is what I call the you know
declarative passport API
um it has what I believe it's like the
ambius API for accessing this history
table
and basically this is a table of all of
those Json records
that are the double bond so
um experience that uh use if you want to
kind of get that information about how
your data set is evolving
thank you
oh I'm sorry I'm just so excited
several coffee break here the big one
has any other questions about time
travel
the Mysteries
so the timestamp that doesn't have to be
exclusively one of these time stamps it
can be something in the range between
these absolutely okay
do you recommend the best practice Folks
at Aquarius basic time stamp or the
you know I think it really depends on
what you're using your Delta tables for
so one thing I things I love about uh
Del public as a technology
um
back when I was doing like more uh
clinical like healthcare analysis that's
down Children's Hospital
I work with much smaller data sets than
I do today
and so back then like uh version as of
was great because I kind of knew I had
like
four versions you know what I mean and
you know it might work the double log
do some experimentation
is very straightforward because they
didn't have a lot to juggle in the head
but it still was the exact same approach
in architecture and tooling as when I
was working with really large data sets
here and there so like I could use the
same apis and approach in the same time
travel helpfulness but you know there's
that sort of just a couple gigabytes
that you know terabytes
um and when I was working with things
that were more on the terabytes you know
but a lot more you know add actions
involved time
uh founded priorities were usually were
helpful and when I had like a smaller
data set of interior updates kind of
version as of was more helpful
in fact like uh for smaller data sets I
would just turn the retention policy off
completely and just keep the full
history because like you know storage as
cheap it was just convenient to have the
history of my you know whatever it might
have data set performance Inception they
didn't really care that I had to get
stuff it was it was fine to put us down
so um yeah I think it just kind of
there's trade-offs but
um you know
it's it'll it becomes very intuitive you
know what will work best for you in the
circumstance
oh yes
so in the examples
[Music]
frame how with something like this work
with click the API where you're pulling
in data based on dates and then
attending
yeah so let's say it's like a Json API
yeah
awesome
um so in this case uh
you're right we're kind of like we've
already made the door frame kind of
manually
the spark has and a lot of the other
apis and tools that you've used to
interact with the filter table
have the methods and parts methods for
other data types so what that would look
like is
um you know you have some process
that is maybe making the API calls or is
it reading like uh
a landing Zone with a bunch of jsons up
there
and it would be Parson at Json into a
data frame and then saving that data
frame uh to Delta table so in a sense
that it's
you know it's a very similar flow even
to this like very uh simple ID example
right
um You just sort of tack on that
business logic that you already probably
have from parsing your data in the case
of common data sets like Json there's
like super helpful like parsers and like
a tooling that will do a lot of that for
you
slowly scroll alone
nice
nice uh and so uh just to kind of get a
better intuition about time travel uh in
the transaction long
uh you know refer to those versions
we're gonna have some collection files
you know file a file a is that one per K
file that could be a reference across
multiple versions so
version zero is good point to file a
this is located version two foreign
and then kind of fast forwarded
to this point the time travel demo but I
can also do a Time episode
and then I mentioned that like as you uh
do more and more transactions uh it
starts to become an efficient to use
Json as your soul
um method for uh updating the Delta
transaction model so I just want to demo
uh the creation of one of those
checkpoint files
um
really try to really do that data
application
so then if we click it here we see all
these additional parquet files because
we've done a bunch of overwrite
operations we haven't completed anything
and then if we go to our Delta log
we now have some additional things other
than Json
we have this checkpoint parquet and
um which will have all the information
of the Json 039 which is 10 Json
and then every time we hit an additional
10 we'll kind of compact that whole
history
in that way reader just has to check out
one compressor part kit plus or minus or
plus uh because there's the
nine jsons or 10 jsons
and then we have the last checkbook I'll
come to the last checkpoint
thanks is that sort of time travel and
transactions
in a nutshell
I want to go over that vacuum operation
as well
and here we have something a little bit
more complicated than the IDS uh
not not much more complicated but you
know Bob Sue
they have a name and an age so there's a
lot more going on for themes
so we're going to make an alternate an
additional Delta table to pack our
to practice backing
and we're going to do the same uh
right operation here
we're going to repartitioned one
you wouldn't normally do that I'm just
doing it so that all of our updates are
just important okay file so it's easier
for me going to the transaction log you
can see what's going on
and I'll write out
Delta format to this so
and then I'll create an additional video
frame with the more individuals
and I'll append
and then we'll just read the table backs
so now we have our idea set up for
works okay now we have a table it has
history
you don't want some of that history
let's go vacuum up some older versions
so the defaults of the tension period is
pretty high
especially for a 90-minute demo so we're
not going to wait around here for 100
hours or whatever it would take
so it's going to throw in here
that's great this is a built-in safety
mechanism so you know while you're time
traveling around your data maybe you're
just a little bit new to the apis or
maybe you have someone else working on
your team that's a little bit weird
today guys it's possible that they can
accidentally do vacuum command and not
quite realize the gravity of the
situation
important you're able to just be
completely whisked away
and so luckily the engine will stop you
not stopping any minute now
I have to give my container that much
assistive resources which
oh absolutely sorry
and also if anyone has any questions
while we're going
yeah
I wanted to connect
uh if that's supported
um
supported catalogs or supported give me
catalog glue
I'm trying to put in some others there's
a lot of options
one that starts with an A that's not
helpful to you but yes you get it you
can register the table so that you could
look them up by their name instead of a
patent
um and yeah I think that's that's
practice
oh yeah
yes uh this isn't the rest one I
unfortunately I think I went a little
bit too slowly through that so I don't
think any will be able to get to the
rest examples uh but I will include them
in the uh the download books so and
we'll add some additional notes to kind
of guide you on your rust journey I
don't mean to give them short sure if
they're really amazing uh but they're
just a slightly less commonly used so I
ordered it this way I kind of don't tell
the high score people the best for last
and I consider if I did a conference
because this is also a python rust
location
this is the jvm ever probably one
oh you know what I think just the
opinion of the Jupiter lab notebook uh
finished or the update because the the
cell is
so the default vacuum operation was
trying to vacuum uh old files older than
the default retention policy which is
100 hours and there were none because
files so just to do anything did it very
slowly but here I said it's zero hours
so that would be everything is on the
table including conversion I'm so sorry
uh this is where that safety
uh
mechanism Catches Us and says are you
sure that seems like a terrible idea
if you're not sure why don't you use the
value that's reasonable like more than
168 hours so let's look it out for you
wants to make sure that you don't
accidentally back in zero thinking maybe
like call it vacuuming the zero with the
version
because that would be the first one
and you know just not have the entire
table because this uses a Time phase in
hours uh cut off for vacuuming
Focus
oh okay
but we can turn that off and then we can
just back him away just destroy
everything
um any questions
uh if you're just doing a Penn
operations and you're say vacuuming old
version so this will keep all your data
or it's going to potentially
file like based on the old stuff nodes
ah great question uh so the question was
you're doing the vacuum operation
um your version zero that you're going
to vacuum away this point to file one
that says your most recent version
uh so because a more recent version is a
point to the file let's say
um
only the files are kind of workman's I
you know we said enough versions are in
trouble
or everyone
uh yeah sorry I was saying that the
history of the table is persistent until
you run the vacuum operator that's
correct yes so basically all history for
adult stable will persist because your
basically keeping multiple versions on
the same part A files and there's a
transaction
now because the log is efficient and
because you're not doing a listing of
files because the files actually exist
in transaction log so you know exactly
where to get them so you're actually not
doing a list on Webb apis this is a
basically what you have for when you're
getting a storage system like object
score
um it's actually just pretty efficient
and you can backstore for a very long
time now the problem for doing that of
course is that your big money
so we do advise you to thank you but we
definitely have a subset of customers
that keep many months and in some cases
years of history now I don't think you
should do a personal view again like you
usually it's more like you do it for
like I want for fiscal reporting
reporting resolution and then what I
would buy for those scenarios is like
well then just generate the fiscal
report from above save that to A
Separate Tables
the history for time travel for Delta
Lake tables
not ready for not
so that's why you want to shorten
awesome uh thank you so much everyone
and then if you are hungry they have set
up food you guys are the closest so if
you want to go now